[Music]
thrilled that Martin Scorcese is on our
show tonight yeah
his latest his latest movie is up for
five Oscars including Best Picture now
the movie has also earned a unique
distinction it has the most f-bombs in
film history
yes 506 mentions of the f-word in just
under three hours now we had some top
scientists look into it that's an
average of 2.8 f words per minute now
this is great news because we
established something on our show a
while ago called the Oscar winner f-bomb
Hall of Fame and as a filmmaker Scorsese
has single-handedly put more f bombs
into the mouths of oscar-winning actors
than anyone in the history of cinema so
right now we're going to give Martin
Scorsese a special Lifetime Achievement
Award take it away
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm here live at the f-bomb Hall of Fame
where we honor Oscar winners who have
said the f-word on our show and tonight
we celebrate filmmaker Martin Scorsese
for his unparalleled contribution to the
proliferation of the f-word in cinema
let's take a look back at some of mr.
Scorsese's finest work and the art of
the f-bomb it's my passion only
Shakespeare oh my what how go homey get
your shine box what guy but in the world
didn't give your word to me for five
grand okay
[Applause]
tonight he joins the ranks of past Hall
of Fame inductees Kevin Spacey and
Javier Bardem whose likenesses have been
cast in these bronze bust as you can see
some of the finest bust makers in
Hollywood were unavailable and tonight
Martin Scorsese is also being
immortalized alongside these other Oscar
winners with his very own hastily
sculpted bust
[Music]
[Applause]
that is absolutely horrible that is the
worst one yet we we think we got a pulse
or vino cheap and just put glasses on it
all right thanks Andy and here it is the
f-bomb Hall of Fame Lifetime Achievement
Award which I am holding right here now
Martin Scorsese couldn't be here in
person he couldn't be here in person to
accept this award because he's backstage
in his dressing room getting ready to
appear in person on this show
congratulations so very happy for you
this awaits you Ivan says he's